in our program aids acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome a part of the
medicine for the laymen series at the
National Institutes of Health we'll take
a closer look at the latest information
on this new disease
in the public interest Primark presents
the following special program as part of
its ongoing dedication to enhancing
health care education and delivery
through its subsidiary the hospital
satellite network
[Music]
hello I'm dr. Linda Reid
welcome to the medicine for the laymen
series at the National Institutes of
Health today we're going to be listening
to dr. Anthony Fauci he's going to be
talking about aids the acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome dr. Falchi is
with a national institute of infectious
diseases in allergy let's find out why
some people came to the lecture I came
because I'm a nursing student at George
Mason University and I'm Co facilitating
a seminar on AIDS with a friend of mine
we came together have you found that you
have been a victim of discrimination
definitely I have definitely been a
victim of discrimination I was fired
from my job I have been refused housing
some medical care has been refused but
not here at the National Institutes are
you worried about the future
definitely definitely right now I'm
while I am on a research protocol at the
National Institutes of Health the
government is paying for me to live in a
hotel and my medical costs are covered
however as soon as my protocol runs out
I have no apartment to go back to I have
no job to go back to and I'm very scared
about what's going to happen to me we've
seen how aids can gravely affect those
who have it and those who are at risk
for it now let's take a look at another
aspect of AIDS research in our cover
story tonight we'll talk with a leading
scientist about his work in AIDS
research in this lab at the National
Institutes of Health the new illness
that has attracted much media attention
called acquired immune deficiency
syndrome or AIDS is being carefully
studied since the disease was first
reported in the United States in mid
1981 scientists have been able to make
some important breakthroughs in the
discovery of what causes the disease
well the most exciting breakthrough is
is unquestionably the fact that in just
a few short years from the recognition
that this disease exists scientists have
been able to identify and isolate the
underlying cause
edia logic agent and AIDS is caused by
htlv 3 the Public Health Service has
received reports of about 5,800 cases of
AIDS with the case fatality ratio of 45%
dr. Anthony Fauci is hopeful that the
answer to this dreaded disease may be
insight I believe now that we have the
agent in hand that the amount of effort
and energy that's being put into it by
biomedical sciences that within a
reasonable period of time will have a
lot of these answers well it's certainly
nice to know that the future looks
brighter now let's go to the lecture and
join dr. Anthony Fauci as he talks about
8:00 this evening what I'd like to do is
discuss with you a topic which I'm sure
all of you to a greater or lesser degree
are aware of it's a topic that has
occupied the interest and energy of a
substantial proportion of the biomedical
research community here at the NIH and
throughout the country and the world
most recently and that is the subject of
the acquired immunodeficiency syndrome
I'm working directly on on AIDS both
clinically and from a basic science
standpoint but it gives me a great deal
of pleasure and excitement to to talk
about AIDS because it really is one of
the few of more actually one of the only
subjects of all of the subjects that we
tackle throughout the years where you
really have to change your lecture every
month because of the extraordinary
advances and evolution of this syndrome
that has provided a great challenge for
the scientists involved in this and has
provided in many respects hope for the
individuals who are afflicted with this
with this terrible syndrome what I'd
like to do this evening is to review for
you some of the most recent advances in
aids as well as provide for you a
background for understanding how we got
to where we are today in our
understanding of AIDS so what I'll be
discussing is some historical aspects of
AIDS the epidemiology or as we say the
profile
I love the syndrome how it came about
the populations that it afflicts we'll
talk about some of the clinical
manifestations or how the disease
expresses itself in the patient
population we can now talk about
something that I couldn't talk about
just a few months ago and that is the
etiology of AIDS and how an
understanding of the etiology has
allowed us to make great advances not
only within the syndrome of AIDS but
also in a number of other diseases that
have immunological components to them
and then finally we'll talk some about
the treatment and prevention of this
syndrome now first of all we must have a
definition of AIDS and I will tell you
right off that the definition that is
given although it is a good definition
in fact it's an excellent definition it
has some serious flaws and the reason
for the flaws are that it's an empiric
definition that is based on the
secondary complications that someone
will get who has AIDS and let me explain
what I mean first we'll go through the
definition it's the presence of
Pneumocystis Carini pneumonia or other
opportunistic infections or Kaposi
sarcoma now for those of you are in a
used to hearing that terminology what it
is is this is the presence of a disease
in an individual that you would not
expect to see in someone who is
otherwise normally immunological II for
example if I said influenza or the
common cold or some other disease you'd
expect to see that in a normal
population in a population that does not
have an immunological defect but these
diseases are present in individuals with
AIDS but the most important component of
this definition is that there's an
absence of a known cause of this
underlying immune deficiency in other
words they have a very severe defect in
the mechanisms that protect them against
these strange infections and against
these tumors which one of which we'll
call Kaposi sarcoma but we can't figure
out a reason why they have that defect
in other words we didn't give them
medications to get this defect they
don't have any underlying tumors that
might cause an immune defect now for
sure this definition is going to change
in the next several months or
thereabouts and the reason is that this
definition does not account for the
large number of individuals who have the
immune defect but have not yet gotten
what we call the secondary complications
namely those infections or those tumors
for example if I had AIDS if I had the
infection with the virus that causes
AIDS which we'll talk about in a moment
but I hadn't yet gotten an infection by
strict definition from the Centers for
Disease Control
I could not be classified as having AIDS
there are a lot of individuals that are
out there that have the defect the
reason it's important to recognize that
is because the statistics that one sees
regarding AIDS are based only on what I
will call whole blown AIDS and do not
take into account the large number of
individuals who have the defect already
another very important aspect of this is
that the transmissibility of the disease
you usually think of someone having AIDS
transmitting the disease to someone else
when in fact as I'll discuss with you in
a bit
the transmissibility might occur prior
to the time that an individual develops
one of these infections and is thereby
classified as having AIDS now now that
we understand that appreciate and
recognize the etiologic agent and we'll
be developing tests for this we might be
able to better get a handle on the
profile of this group of patients
[Music]
historically we first recognized this
disease actually as a new disease in
1981 the cases were first brought to the
attention of the Centers for Disease
Control of the CDC in 1979 in the summer
of 1981 there were reports of unusual
infections and/or tumors in otherwise
healthy homosexual men now again if I
were giving you this lecture when we
started working on AIDS
a few years ago I would be spending the
first 10 minutes or so trying to
convince the audience that we were
dealing with a new disease in fact we
don't need to waste any time on that
this is a new disease at least in the
United States where it came from we'll
discuss in a short while but in the
United States it's new and it's very
interesting and somewhat perplexing to
have gone through as an investigator
those early years in AIDS because when
you're dealing with the new syndrome
like that and you don't really
understand it anyone's hypothesis about
what this might be
is held in equal respect to a well
thought-out hypothesis and I think that
led to a lot of the misunderstanding not
only regarding AIDS in general but
regarding the entire homosexual
population and how they may have been
the early victims of this particular
disease and as I'm sure you're all well
aware there was an extraordinary amount
of difficulty in that regard
particularly with the intensification of
the already existing unfortunate
discrimination against these individuals
I can remember in early in the summer of
1981 when I first read in the report
from the CDC of these cases of strange
infections and tumors in patient and in
in male homosexuals in the New York City
area and in California LA in San
Francisco
I had thought initially
that this might be a transmissible agent
but maybe with some toxic substance some
drug or what-have-you that they had
ingested but then when it became clear
that's such a large number of
individuals on both coasts were getting
it we became rather suspicious that we
were dealing with an infectious agent
and then as soon as the IV drug users
became infected and then hemophiliacs
with the common denominator of the
possibility of blood-borne transmission
in addition to sexual transmission then
it became clear that we were dealing
with a very special unprecedented
situation which will have the
opportunity to go through with you
[Music]
what do we mean by risk groups the risk
groups are those individuals who because
of the epidemiology or the profile of
the disease appear to be at a particular
risk of getting the disease now if one
looks at the profile in the United
States seventy one or more percent of
the individuals with this full-blown
AIDS now are homosexual or bisexual men
seventeen and a half percent of them are
intravenous drug users four percent of
Haitians a little less than one percent
I hemophiliacs and about six percent of
them don't fall into any of the known
above risk groups this number is much
less now because there's been an
expansion of the risk groups which are
related to now our understanding of the
etiology and transmissibility of this
disease I'll get to in some of the
latest slides how this disease which we
surmised early on started off in the
male homosexual population in this
country not that there was anything
intrinsically different or wrong or
what-have-you about homosexuality it was
very simple its straightforward
epidemiology you take an infectious
agent and you introduce it into a
population in which the spread among
those individuals if it's sexual contact
spread it's a perfect setup to spread in
any event what we had was a
concentration of cases as you'll see
here in the New York metropolitan area
in New York City in New Jersey and in
Los Angeles and San Francisco in
California some of the data that I'll be
showing you now is based on the first
4,000 cases of AIDS in this country
right now in October of 1984 there are
greater than 6,000 documented cases of
full-blown AIDS in the United States now
this color diagram with the darker areas
being the most
intense areas with regard to the
populations involved as you can see now
it's spread into most of the states in
the United States as a matter of fact it
is spread throughout the world but the
earlier concentration in New York and
California again merely reflected that
since the majority of the patients at
that time were male homosexuals there is
a great concentration of what has been
called fast lane homosexuals and I'll
explain what I mean by that in a moment
here in New York City and in the two
cities in California fast lane is an
unfortunate term that's used to
designate a large large amount or a
great degree of sexual contact namely
large numbers of sexual partners in many
cases anonymous sexual partners now
people kind of get hung up on that with
regard to the concept of homosexuality
and that's unfortunate because all that
is telling us is that if someone has
multiple sexual contacts and has a
sexually transmitted disease
that disease will spread within that
population and that's exactly what we
were seeing and as you can see the
breakdown of New York San Francisco
Miami etc is right there at the time
that the disease was first recognized we
had no idea that this was a viral agent
that was introduced into the population
so investigators particularly the
Centers for Disease Control the CDC try
to collect a wide range of epidemiologic
data namely what is the profile what is
the profile of these patients and the
information merely bounce back as
telling us what the profile of the risk
groups were for example at the time this
data was collected we knew that the
majority were male homosexuals but there
were as a rather substantial group that
were IV drug users and if one looks at
race ethnicity the reason we broke it
down into race ethnicity
to determine if there was any factor
genetic or otherwise which would
predispose someone to AIDS
as you can see about 58 percent of the
individuals were white non-hispanic if
you did a profile of the male
homosexuals in New York in California
the majority of them would be white
non-hispanics there was a lesser group
that were black non-hispanics and others
were Hispanics if you look at the IV
drug users in those major cities the
majority of them would be blacks and
Hispanics so all we were seeing were
profile of the risk groups the same held
true if we try to break them down by age
most of the individuals was seen between
the twenty and forty nine year age group
all that told us is that is exactly the
age group where most of the actively
practicing male homosexual population in
this country is again merely a
reflection of the epidemiology of the
risk group and didn't really tell us
much about the disease
now what about transmissibility of AIDS
again I need not go into the data
explaining why we know now for sure that
a this is a new agent and B this agent
is transmitted by sexual contact and by
blood or blood products
now I suggested the hypothesis to you a
few minutes ago that the disease started
off in this country within the male
homosexual population and that's exactly
what happened there are some theories of
how it got introduced into the male
homosexual population if that is the
case which indeed it is then the
transmissibility will relate to the
contacts within the male homosexual
population as well as the overlap
between the male homosexual population
and other populations that became risk
groups and now that's very clearly seen
now you keep getting asked why the male
homosexual pop
halation well as I mentioned for reasons
that will become clear shortly the virus
was introduced into the population and
it's a sexually transmitted disease
therefore sexual contact spreads the
disease since male homosexual
individuals almost invariably not always
confine their homosexual activities or
their sexual activities to other male
homosexuals what you are going to have
is a compounding and a spread within
that group there's nothing intrinsic
about homosexuality that would make them
susceptible to the disease if you want
to create an analogy let us say that
this disease was transmitted by sneezing
which it is not it is clearly not
transmitted that way then if you had the
disease introduced into schoolchildren
school children would have it in a
rampant form because they sneeze all
over each other not to mention people
who ride the subways and elevators and
things like that that's not the way this
disease is spread it is spread by sexual
transmission and it was introduced into
a population in which sexual contact is
rather substantial with regard to
numbers the same thing holds true for
blood or blood products it can be
transmitted by blood or blood products
so what is the link then with how the
disease got out of the homosexual
population into other risk groups this
is diagrammed here on this slide because
if you look at the male homosexual
population a proportion of them a small
proportion but nonetheless a proportion
of them overlap with intravenous drug
users since this is a virus then the
virus can go by blood-borne transmission
now from the homosexual group to the
needles of IV drug uses hence you now
have it in IV drug users who spread it
among themselves by sharing the needle
which is contaminated by
this virus we know that individuals can
be walking around carrying the virus and
not know it
they give blood transfusions they give
blood products that will ultimately be
translated or transformed into plasma
products to be given to the hemophiliacs
who need those clotting factors to
reconstitute the deficient clotting
hence the disease can then overlap into
the haemophiliac population and as I'm
going to show you in a moment that risk
group of the four major risk groups has
expanded some for the reasons which I
have just explained mainly contact
between the original risk groups and
other risk groups which have now
accumulated and on this slide what we
have is what we'll call the expanded
risk groups we spoken about the first
the second the third and the fourth
now the Haitian situation has created
some controversy in this country and the
reason is that we have public health
officials have designated the Haitians
as a separate risk group now the
objection to that and it's a reasonable
objection is that discriminates against
Haitians why should you call the
Haitians a separate risk group we call
them a separate risk group because only
a very small percentage of the Haitian
population their AIDS can be explained
by homosexual activity or IV drug use so
there's something else going on there
and we'll get to that when we talk about
what we're calling now the African
connection transfusion related again the
disease is clearly transmitted from
transfusions does that mean you should
feel unsafe about getting a transfusion
now because the risk is so small that
the chances of getting AIDS from a
transfusion are less than the chances of
somebody mixing up the blood and giving
you the wrong blood and you're winding
up with a transfusion reaction and dying
from it so the fact is from an
epidemiological standpoint we must be
aware of that but the risk is not great
so the fear of getting a blood
transfusion is unwarranted female sexual
partners of AIDS patients or persons at
risk for AIDS a very important clue of
the of the profile of that disease in
this country because the female sexual
partners of bisexual males or of IV drug
users have gotten the disease what we
haven't seen and it is probably the
reason why this disease has not spread
rapidly into other risk groups is that
we're not seeing what we call back
transmission or transmission from a
woman back to a man and that has an
important implication that is different
from what we're seeing as I'll mention
shortly in the African connection now
children and households of AIDS patients
we'll get back to that in a moment
certain black Africans such as those in
Chad's a year etc in persons and none of
the above risk groups this number 9 is
really rather small let's take a look at
some of these risk groups can it be
transmitted by blood transfusions
clearly we have documented a significant
number of cases of transfusion related
AIDS in other words someone who is
carrying the virus donated blood and
that whole blood or blood products
within transfused into an individual who
was not in any of the other risk groups
that individual two years three years
and even as late as four or five years
comes down with AIDS the question that's
very interesting and important is that
blood was given to a large number of
individuals why does only maybe one or
two come down with AIDS and the reason
for that is probably related to what we
call cofactors or there are intrinsic or
innate susceptibility to getting AIDS
which if you don't have that even if
you're exposed to the agent you won't
get it in essence AIDS is a difficult
disease to catch it definitely is a
difficult disease to catch we know how
its transmitted but you can be exposed
to that agent
and not at all get the disease moving on
then to other possibilities what about
heterosexual contact I gave you the
example of the heterosexual female
partner of a male with AIDS heterosexual
contact indeed is one of the major nodes
of transmission for example in Africa
that's different than in the United
States we don't know why if a woman has
AIDS in in the u.s. population she will
at least buy the data so far not
transmit the disease back to her male
heterosexual partner now there is a lot
of hypothesis of why that is so and
again we don't know for sure but one of
the possibilities is that the disease
although it's sexually transmitted needs
to enter into the blood stream now from
heterosexual contact from vaginal
intercourse it is unlikely that the
agent can break through the vaginal
mucosa but that is not the case if one
thinks for example of the anal
intercourse that is the common practice
in the homosexual population which may
be one of the reasons why those that the
small rinse or tears and rectal mucosa
may be a perfect entry site for the
virus again these are things that you'll
read about and that you'll hear about
the proof of that is not really
well-established aids in infants now you
might remember some time ago when the
newspapers broke that AIDS was seen in
infants in households of an individual
at risk for AIDS or who had AIDS it was
that which brought to focus the
possibility in the conjecture on the
part of the lay press that perhaps aids
could be spread by casual contact namely
by having an infant or a child in a home
being rocked or put on the knee of an
uncle who was an IV drug user and in
fact was harboring the virus that was
very unfortunate
because what that led to was a fear that
maybe it was transmitted by casual
contact we know now from the work of Bob
Gallo and his colleagues that if you
examine the infants with AIDS and their
mothers the mother in three out of four
cases has the virus in an asymptomatic
way in other words the child did not get
it from casual contact or even close
intimate contact that you would give to
a baby the child got it either
intrauterine Li or Perry
Nataly because the mother had the virus
so that brings us then to a question
that is very important and that is asked
constantly of me and my colleagues in
this area can AIDS be transmitted by
casual contact and we've learned to
never say never and never say always in
medicine but we've also learned to look
at the scientific data and the
scientific data is overwhelming that in
fact aids cannot be transmitted by
casual contact in other words a way to
someone in the elevator
someone's sneezing on you or even
someone embracing you or hugging you or
holding your hand is not going to
transmit AIDS so the fear of individual
to either have AIDS or at risk group for
AIDS transmitted transmitting AIDS is a
understandable fear but really my
translate into uncalled for
discrimination which in unfortunately
has been the case and that's an issue
that I really must emphasize over and
over again that there is no scientific
evidence at all that it can be
transmitted by casual contact now what
about the geographic origin of AIDS what
I'm going to tell you in the next couple
of minutes and in this next two slides
is scientific data and I'll tell you
what the data and then some speculation
the scientific data is that aids exists
in Africa in Central Africa particularly
in Ziya it exists in a rather
substantial way the incidence of AIDS in
Zaire is as great as it is per hundred
thousand population as it is in San
Francisco if one does epidemiologic
study by examining the serie of
individuals in Africa we know that the
disease existed there in the early 70s
before it existed in the United States
is then Central Africa the source or the
origin of AIDS in the United States
I don't know that now we're talking
about hypothesis let me tell you another
fact in the late 60s and early 70s
thousands not a few but thousands of
Haitians came to Zion particularly in
Kinshasa the capital to work as
technical advisors for the Zion
government after several years there
because of the nationalization of much
of the industry they were essentially
kicked out of Zaire and came back to
Haiti to the United States and to Canada
is that a possible connection the answer
is yes because it is very likely that
the male homosexuals in New York City
who frequently traveled to
port-au-prince in Haiti for vacations
and for sexual contacts down there
picked up the virus in Haiti and then
because of the mobility of the
population between New York and the west
coast there was spread back and forth
from the west coast in addition the
early cases in Europe in France the
early cases in in in England and in
Germany can be clearly traced to
homosexual contacts from individuals who
resided in New York but there's also a
very important clue there because most
of the cases in Belgium in fact were
among black Africans who had come from
Zaire and had gone to Belgium for
medical assistance as you probably know
Zaire was formerly the Belgian Congo so
there's a great deal of
link between Belgium ins ie that was the
first clue that perhaps the disease
might have originated there so we don't
know really scientifically where it
originated but a series of
circumstantial happenings strongly
suggest that this may have been the
original focus and how it happened to
get introduced into the male homosexual
population
[Music]
what about the clinical manifestations
of AIDS in other words what happens to
individuals who get full-blown AIDS well
first of all there are what we call
opportunistic infections and I'll
explain that in a moment then there is
tumors called Kaposi sarcoma which will
explain
there's an interesting syndrome called
chronic lymphadenopathy there are
certain other tumors and there are what
we call autoimmune phenomenon which
merely reflect an aberrancy of the
body's immune system what do we mean
when we say opportunistic infection an
opportunistic infection is an infection
which occurs in a person whose defense
mechanisms are impaired
hence the microorganism uses the
opportunity to invade the person because
of a weakened defenses in other words it
takes the opportunity hence it is an
opportunistic infection you wouldn't
expect to see that infection in
individuals who have normal immunity and
here are some of these opportunistic
infections they have very strange names
that I'm not going to run through but
I'm going to give you some examples of
them it's important to realize that
these were big red flags for us early on
in our study of AIDS because you would
not expect an otherwise healthy
individual like a healthy young
homosexual man to get any of these
things unless something was very very
wrong with his immune system the first
is a particular type of pneumonia which
is called Pneumocystis Carini pneumonia
which is caused by a protozoan organism
that is ubiquitous it is all over
it's in my lung the reason I don't have
Pneumocystis Carini pneumonia because my
defense mechanisms are keeping that
organism in check if I were to take
drugs that were markedly
immunosuppressed me there would be a
reasonably good chance that I would get
that pneumonia that's what happens to
the AIDS individuals as I'll show you
when we talk about immunology they're
substantial
immunosuppressed what about this
microorganism it's called Mycobacterium
avium intracellular re again a bizarre
illness I have been doing infectious
disease consults in this building for
the last 16 and a half years and I had
seen one case of Mycobacterium avium
intracellular re in cancer patients who
we immunosuppressed with chemotherapy we
see it all the time now in our patients
with AIDS here's an individual who has
oral thrush or Candida in the mucosal
membrane of their mouth it can also
affect the esophagus this is an x-ray of
an esophagus in which we pour dye down
the esophagus and what you see it's
difficult if you haven't read these
before but this should be a very smooth
surface because your esophagus is very
smooth which allows the the food to go
down there in an almost imperceptible
way here are what we call scalloping of
the esophagus that's due to the invasion
of the mucosa by the candida
microorganism and also there's a disease
called cytomegalovirus which is a virus
that isn't the cause of AIDS but it's
one of those opportunistic infections
that comes in and attacks an individual
and here is a photograph of the eye of a
patient of mine with AIDS which as you
can see is what we call chewed up and
I'll show you what we mean by that when
one compares it with a normal retina see
the smoothness and the easy ability to
look at the blood vessel this is what it
looks like in an AIDS patient the virus
has infiltrated the cells of the retina
what about tumors and AIDS well Kaposi
sarcoma will explain in a moment and
diffuse undifferentiated Hodgkin's
lymphoma now what do I mean by that all
that means is that there's a particular
type of a tumor of a particular type of
a cell that is seen in these individuals
with AIDS these are the typical skin
lesions of Kaposi sarcoma now what
Kaposi sarcoma it's a tumor of those
cells which make up blood vessels what
we call them endothelial cells the
disease is usually confined to the skin
but an AIDS patients it spreads to all
organs of the body
10% of Kaposi sarcoma and non AIDS
patients spreads elsewhere
75% of AIDS patients who have kappa
she's will have spread if you do not
check the disease if this kappa she's
can really come in very strange places
here it is in the eyelid of an
individual there is a syndrome that's
related to AIDS called chronic
lymphedema the-- and all that is is
swelling of the lymph glands either in
the groin in the axilla in the neck or
cervical area if I were giving this
lecture eight months ago I would have a
slide that had a question what is the
relationship of chronic lymphatic operty
to AIDS is it related well we now know
from virus isolation that greater than
85 percent of individuals with this
syndrome have the virus in them the real
question that we don't know the answer
to now in October of 1984 is what
proportion of those individuals will
ultimately go on to develop AIDS the key
or the secret to protection against
full-blown AIDS maybe in these chronic
lymphedema pathy patients in other words
why aren't they all getting AIDS we're
studying these individuals to try and
determine what component of their immune
response is keeping the AIDS virus in
check we do know with regard to my
question of the relationship of
persistent lymph adenopathy to AIDS that
from 2.5 to 17 to 19 percent of those
individuals over a two to three-year
period will develop AIDS we don't know
what the five and ten-year figure will
be now what about the fatality of this
disease before we get on to the etiology
and immunology the number that is given
by the Centers for Disease Control is
approximately
43% of all the patients but if you break
them down from individuals who were
diagnosed in 1979 and look up to the
point of individuals who diagnosed this
year one can see that there are very few
if any individuals still alive who had
the disease back in 1979 obviously there
are a large number here 80% of them are
alive who were diagnosed in 1984 right
now the ultimate mortality of someone
who has full-blown AIDS namely already
has the the the secondary complications
might approach a hundred percent now
when you say that you've got now well
wait a minute there are a lot of people
out there who have AIDS are they all
going to die the answer to that is we
don't know but that's the way the
research is going now that is the reason
why we are furiously looking at means be
them direct attack on the virus itself
or attempt to reconstitute the immune
response with various factors such that
we can curb this very high fatality rate
and we won't have a hundred percent
mortality and we have a lot of hope that
in fact given the work that's going on
now we might see a realization of that
hope in in sometime hopefully very soon
[Music]
what about the etiology of AIDS I've
been alluding throughout this entire
discussion to this virus that causes
AIDS what about this virus what is it
I'm sure you've heard about it in the
paper we call it the human t-cell
leukemia lymphoma virus or htlv 3 and
the reason we call it that
was that a few years ago Bob Gallo from
the Cancer Institute here at the NIH had
discovered that a virus a retrovirus as
we call it and that's what it is a
retrovirus because it has a particular
type of an enzyme in it which gives you
a reversal of the usual genetic process
of propagating itself was causing this
htlv-1 was causing adult t-cell
lymphomas and leukemias that were
endemic in Japan in the Caribbean and in
certain southeastern states of the
United States in fact a variant of this
htlv-1 which we've been calling htlv 3
is in fact the etiologic agent of AIDS
an agent was discovered in France which
the French call lymph adenopathy
associated virus or lav it's the same
thing as htlv 3 so the virus in Europe
in Africa in the United States is the
same here is its schematic diagram
showing you that this virus has a
propensity to attack a particular type
of cell that's a really truly critical
point because before we knew what the
virus was the only thing we knew is that
our patients had a selective defect of a
particular type of a cell and it was a T
helper cell and I'll explain what I mean
by that in a moment that was the clue
for the individuals who are doing the
virology to look for a virus that
infected t4 cells or helper cells now we
already knew from Gallo's work that
lymphoproliferative or adult t-cell
leukemia was caused by this virus so
therefore a major effort was directed at
determining if a variant of this virus
could action
cause depletion of lymphocytes or
acquired immunodeficiency syndrome and
as it turned out a variant of that virus
in fact caused the syndrome we have to
understand some basic fundamentals about
the immune system there are major
components of the immune system there
are cells called b-cells we call it B
because it's bone marrow derived or
bursar equivalent it's it's it's a
technical term that merely connotes that
this cell has a certain derivation but
its function is what's important it
makes the antibodies thus those proteins
that attack microorganisms b-cells
produce antibodies we need them for our
defenses in addition to b-cell there's a
very interesting kind of cell call a
helper cell the reason we call it a
helper cell it is because it is
responsible for helping not only this
b-cell but all other cells perform their
function it's the catalyst that makes
the immune system go it's the focal cell
that orchestrates the immune system this
T cell is called T because it's derived
from the thymus gland and it is a t4
cell because it has a designation of a
monoclonal antibody that can recognize
it or some technique that we use to
identify it and it has inducer a helper
function in addition to balance the
immune response
we have suppressor cells which can
actually dampen down the immune system
so we have B cells making the antibodies
T cell doing the orchestration
suppressor cells keeping the lid on
things so that the immune system doesn't
run away with itself when it does as a
matter of fact that's how you get
autoimmune disease which is a different
topic that we don't have time to discuss
this evening with that is a very basic
background of the immune system
how does htl b3 affect these human
t-cells well it selectively infects the
T cell it has what we call a tropism for
it if you put a lot of cells in the tube
and you throw an HT ld3 it'll go right
for that t4 cell and infect it it hasn't
for the helper cell it seems to leave
the suppressor cell alone and it damages
but does not immediately kill the cell
but ultimately depletes the cell this t4
cell as I alluded to earlier is the
critical cell what it does is that it's
responsible in a direct or indirect way
for virtually everything the immune
system does it induces suppressor cells
and induces killer cells you don't have
to remember all this to just merely get
the concept that if teleologically I
wanted to pick out the one cell that if
I damage that cell I would do the most
damage to the immune system I as an
immunologist would pick out the t4 cell
that's exactly what this virus did it
picked out the t4 cell and it created a
tremendous amount of damage in the
immune system now in the peripheral
blood of man about 60 percent of the
cells or helper cells and about 30
percent of them as suppressor cells what
happens in AIDS is that we start losing
these helper cells and if you look at
the profile immunologically of any of my
AIDS patients what you'll see is that
they're markedly deficient in their t4
or helper cells
now the immunological abnormalities and
AIDS first of all as I mentioned just
now there's a quantitative t-cell defect
now I can't expect anybody except an
immunologist in the audience to be able
to understand what this profile is but
there's something in it that I chose to
show you even if you don't understand
immunology this is a computerized
technique of writing out the amount of
cells that an individual has in their
blood this is the background as you can
see there's nothing there this is the t4
blip on the computer of the helper cells
in a normal healthy individual who is
the identical twin by the way of this
patient with AIDS if you look at the
AIDS patient this individual has
virtually no helper cells the suppressor
cells are normal normal blip in each in
each individual the normal individual
and the
individual with AIDS there's a
functional t-cell defect in other words
this helper cell here which I've
schematically diagrammed as being
infected with this h TL b3 generally
tells us b-cell what to do tell some of
the other cells what to do usually there
are about two of these to every one of
these what happens in AIDS these get
depleted and these fellows take over
what else do we see an AIDS there's a
b-cell hyperactivity in other words
there's factors likely that are released
by this infected t-cell which trigger
that b-cell in addition the b-cell
itself we know now might be susceptible
under certain circumstances to infection
with this htlv 3 what does that mean
with regard to the patient's ability to
respond to a particular stimulus that is
suppressed because the b-cell which is
supposed to recognize these foreign
antigens doesn't do it anymore because
it's remarkably weakened because it has
been one either infected with the virus
or as I mentioned earlier it requires a
good healthy t-cell to kind of push it
to do what it wants to do what it needs
its help from the t-cell that's why we
call it a helper t-cell but the helper
t-cells are gone in this patient so the
b-cell cannot respond well another
insult to the immune system also the
monocyte which is a cell that's
responsible for killing a lot of
infections this is blocked in AIDS
patients how can that be well by a
number of mechanisms this T helper cell
here he comes again
that cell is responsible for telling the
monocyte what to do if I get infected
for example I've made the analogy of the
Pneumocystis Carini pneumonia in in my
lung why aren't I getting Pneumocystis
pneumonia because my t-cells
are telling my monocyte to make sure
that those Pneumocystis don't grow very
much now if I don't have those
t---cells the monocytes not going to
know that and I'm going to get
Pneumocystis carinii pneumonia that's
exactly what's happening in aids in
addition in our body there are a number
of cells which we call killer cells that
are responsible for killing either virus
infected targets or tumor cells they're
our way of surveilling they look around
they want to see if there's a virus
around if there is they attack it they
look around to see if there's a tumor
around they attack it the same problem
exists these cells don't do very well
unless that t4 helper cell is prodding
them on so although we have normal
numbers of these cells they're not
hearing any information they're not
getting marching orders from the t4 cell
so what this slide here does is that
essentially summarizes how this focal
cell here which is infected with the
deadly virus is responsible for the
activity of almost all of the other
cells that have something to do with
immunity in our body
for example the B cell as I mentioned
just to review for you the B cell cannot
do any of the things it's supposed to do
the monocyte macrophage can kill because
it's not getting the signal the t4
induction of other cells such as the
natural killer cell they don't work
right other t4 cells which is supposed
to do other things immunologically don't
do don't work right other cell types
such as suppressor cells in other words
this hypothetical scheme which is no
more hypothesis explains the apparent
paradox of the immune defect
what is that paradox you have one cell
that's infected specifically with a
virus that has a given function and yet
when you look at the immune system it is
globally wiped out so hack in one cell
caused a global wipe out of a system
that's made up of so many different
cells and the reason is that those
different cells are critically the
and then upon that one cell that's the
victim of the virus now what about the
treatment and prevention of AIDS that is
a very difficult problem prevention by
public health awareness of contacts the
male homosexual community has responded
in a most encouraging extraordinary way
of educating themselves and their their
their brethren about the dangers of
certain types of contacts of anonymous
contacts and preventing the spread among
themselves that is an important point
we'll get to in a moment vaccination
which is a potential a real potential
for prevention of this disease what have
we been doing and what have been some of
the very discouraging results which
although they are in and of themselves
discouraging have nonetheless provided
information which we feel will be the
foundation for investigation which we
hope and believe deep down will not be
as discouraging as we have experienced
in the past first of all what you have
to do is you have to treat the
opportunistic infections and/or Kaposi
sarcoma we're doing that we tried
immunological reconstitution with bone
marrow transplants and lymphocyte
transfusion it did not work why didn't
it work it did not work because the
virus was still in the individual
immunological enhancement we're now
trying factors that are made by the
lymphocytes giving them to individuals
for a number of reasons to try and boost
up their immune response to perhaps
curtail the virus in a way that we don't
think will completely eliminate it but
curtail it enough so that when we
develop an agent that has specific
activity against the virus namely
something that can kill the htlv 3 then
we can combine that with these
reconstitution experiments which will
hopefully no longer be experiments but
will be common practice and those two
things together might then
individuals who are already infected
with the virus by a combination of
killing the virus and reconstituting the
immune response and finally as you I'm
sure have read in the papers given the
fact that we now have the virus in our
hands it is quite possible in fact it's
invariable that we will develop a
vaccine for AIDS the question that
remains to be answered is will that
vaccine be effective in protecting
individuals against infection with the
virus and we don't know that but that's
exactly where much of the research is
going on at the present time in summary
then we have discussed the broad
implications clinically and otherwise of
the acquired immunodeficiency syndrome
AIDS
we know now that it is an is caused by
an infectious agent that is a
transmissible disease and that it works
it's damaging effects by specifically
modulating in a negative way the immune
system we don't know a lot about AIDS
but we also know an incredible amount
about it from our experience over the
past three or four years and hopefully
our recent advances of being able to
isolate identify and characterize the
agent together with the advances in
understanding the natural history and
pathophysiology of this disease will
allow us over the next year to come back
to you and tell you that we now not only
have hope and hypothesis but that we
have a real prevention and indeed a real
cure thank you let's recap the most
important points from the lecture AIDS
is a new disease that first appeared in
the United States in 1979 there are two
major groups at risk for AIDS
homosexuals and IV drug users in this
country also there are other multiple
risk groups aids can be transmitted
sexually or through blood or blood
products the clinical manifestations of
AIDS are multiple
opportunistic infections and unusual
neoplasms the cause of AIDS is htlv 3 a
virus which selectively infects a subset
of lymphocytes multiple approaches to
prevention and treatment are mostly in
the experimental stages
these include vaccine development
antiviral chemotherapy directed against
htlv 3 an immunological reconstitution
thank you for joining us I'm dr. Linda
Reed for the hospital satellite network
[Music]
the preceding program has been a
presentation of the hospital satellite
network
[Music]
you